you can have really high standards for
things but you have to allow yourself to
do a lot of volume and make mistakes
rather than feeling like you have to
strain that big beautiful brain of yours
to come up with ideas you can literally
snatch them from all around you I have
so much energy and I didn't see myself
sitting behind a desk doing corporate
finance that is one of probably the
biggest mistaken notions that we have
culturally is that the feminine is weak
and it is not
okay let's keep laughs with rule number
one have high standards one of the
things about my team in particular is we
do share a lot of DNA so everyone does
have very high standards they want to be
the best they want to crush it they want
to come out with new things they want to
be innovative they want to always be at
that next level so I can only play with
people like that because they're the
only people that get my kind of little
weirdness and craziness so that's number
one number two is we're also realists
and we've been in this game long enough
to realize you're not gonna hit a home
run every single time I always like to
call it the SNL effect like I love SNL I
think it's a great show I've always
watched it you know but you don't get to
dick in a box unless you actually do all
of these other skits I mean it was one
of the funniest in my opinion I know
people like oh but it was one of the
funniest skits back in the day it was
hilarious and I remember watching that
thing so many times and going like this
is genius remember Justin Timberlake and
it was just like this whole thing again
in today's culture in 2019 culture that
would get ripped apart I'm talking about
in that particular moment in time I
thought it was funny you don't get to
some of their most hilarious skits
unless you produce a lot of work so
coming back to your point in terms of
high standards you can have really high
standards for things but you have to
allow yourself to do a lot of volume and
make mistakes so an example was in the
fall we went out and did some things on
the road that it was a new thing and
we're not using any of the footage
because it wasn't very good I'm not
crying on my cereal over that that's
like part of the game so I think it's
very possible to have high standards
which is different than perfectionism
and allow yourself the Grace and the
space to play an experiment and fall on
your face or not use stuff also if you
want to have more confidence check out
my 254 series it's free the link to join
is in the description below because
being a really really good listener is
one of the most underrated secrets to
success when I was bartending I was
fully bartending like I wasn't talking
to myself about oh my god I should be
dancing right now or I should be working
on my coaching practice rule number two
get ideas from everywhere rather than
feeling like you have to strain that big
beautiful brain of yours
come up with ideas you can literally
snatch them from all around you because
everyday life contains endless material
things that you overhear something you
notice out the window maybe it's a lyric
from a song or a scene from something on
TV an interaction that you had in the
line at Starbucks literally content is
everywhere it's like air but unlike air
you can snatch it so here's an example
one day I was here in New York City and
I overheard this woman on her cell phone
as she walked past me she was super
upset she was frustrated and she said
I'm just not great with financial stuff
I just can't handle it and yes she was
British so immediately I whipped out my
cellphone and I shot this video right
here and I talked about why is so
important that people stop telling
themselves these negative stories about
money and I talked about how important
it is especially for women to take
charge of their finances then a couple
hours later I slapped that thing up on
Facebook and boom contents snatched and
hatched
rule number three follow your intuition
I studied finance in college and I
remember knowing I have so much energy
and I didn't see myself sitting behind a
desk doing corporate finance and I
thought the only place that I could
possibly thrive was on the floor of the
New York Stock Exchange because there's
actually no physical seats you run
around all day long it's kind of crazy
and intense and it sounded pretty
awesome to me and when I got there I
felt so grateful to actually have a job
and have a good job and it was so
exciting feeling like you're in the
center of the financial universe and
when I looked at all the people around
me you know they were making tons of
money like ridiculous amounts of money
more than I could even comprehend but as
time went on I started to realize that
they weren't happy and I wasn't
happening it was like everyone I worked
with they only looked forward to these
two weeks a year that they had vacation
I was like this is not my life this is
not what I'm supposed to do and this
little voice inside me kept saying this
is not where you're meant to be you're
meant to do something bigger you're
meant to do something greater but the
whole problem was that little voice
didn't tell me what I was supposed to be
doing it just was saying this isn't it
so eventually it got so loud and for me
my intuition speaks very viscerally like
I hear things inside and it starts to
get so uncomfortably physically that I
have to make a move and I finally found
myself one day so miserable I felt like
I was gonna cry and I had to actually
leave the floor and I walked out and
bright near Wall Street there's Trinity
Church and I was raised Catholic and so
I saw the church I was like I have to go
to the church and I sat on the steps and
I pulled out my cell phone I call my
parents I was crying my eyes out I felt
like such a loser because I grew up in a
very middle-class family and my parents
busted their buns to put me through
school and here I was having this safe
and secure job for all intensive
purposes an amazing job and I wanted to
quit and I didn't know what I wanted to
do and so I just told them I don't want
to you know be a failure but I can't do
this anymore my dad said something so
powerful to me I don't know
forget it he said don't worry about the
money he's like you have to figure out
what you love if you figure out
something that you love to do everything
else is going to take care of itself so
if you've got to quit quit and
everything will work out and I remember
I walked back into the floor and I like
had don't you know wipe my face and that
was the beginning of the end I think
within like two weeks I gave my notice
and I had to leave
remember for exercise when I take a spin
class a really good spin class where I'm
loving the music and I can absolutely
let go and charge into my body I can
like feel into every single movement I
can let the sweat pour off of me I can
get lost in them in the rhythm I find
that it opens up a channel in me like
nothing else sometimes it could be
taking a great walk I think I want to
push you a little bit on yeah there's a
channel so I really understand it yes is
it where you feel like you can hear the
little voice in your mind is where your
ear on eclis you can't try and force it
to show up so often times when I hit a
roadblock in my business and I'm just at
this stalemate I'm like oh I can go this
way or this way I'm stuck let me go work
out let me go take a walk let me take a
spin class let me take a dance class and
get immersed in that so that my
subconscious and the rest of my body has
a chance to work through it and it will
produce an answer or an insight when I'm
not looking for it it could happen at
the end of the class when I'm done in
the shower sometimes it happens on the
bike it doesn't matter but what you just
have to do is have a level of faith and
trust and you can't go in forcing it I
feel like what happens through exercise
and again it's when you have that level
of faith to surrender to your body to
surrender that you have wisdom within
you that you're not going to access
grinding to it it unfurls almost like a
flower blooms when it's ready number
five be consistent as someone who's been
consistently creating content and
sharing content for almost two decades
now I speak from experience and I got to
tell you being consistent with your
content creation it is so important it's
actually one of the biggest factors in
our company's success so when it comes
to coming up with things to write about
or talk about or teach about I really do
believe that I can never run out of
ideas because literally there's always
more where that came from
look people we live in an abundant
ever-changing ever-expanding universe
it's literally impossible to run out of
ideas
I promise you now this doesn't mean that
I never feel like I run out of ideas or
that I don't occasionally wonder if I'm
tapped out I mean believe me I have
those moments but when that happens I
remember my magical mantra that there's
always more where that came from and it
changes everything like that because
there's always another story to tell
there's always another way for me to
serve there's always someone who could
use a helping hand or a kind word or a
reminder about how frigging great they
are and from that space ideas always
always come real number six go the extra
mile wherever you are on the plane
JetBlue has really given thought to the
details and I love this so for example
free Wi-Fi and I know it sounds silly
but so many damn flights that I've taken
make me pay this extra twenty five or
thirty bucks just to get worked on when
I've already paid a ton of money to fly
so free Wi-Fi for the entire plane I
gotta say that's a nice perk when we're
all so used to being nickel and dimed
next I got to talk about snacks so on
longer flights they have this
self-service snack situation in the
economy cabin which is so humane and I
have to tell you that in mint which is
their business class that I fly because
I mean business Brett and my fantastic
supercool flight attendant brought me
this refreshing lime mint spritzer I was
so impressed with that beverage branding
flying in mint class and getting a mint
drink nicely done and last but not least
Brett also called me by my first name
Murray instead of Miss forleo now of
course he could have called me for Leo
and I would have been down for that but
who doesn't want to hear their first
name and he kept calling me by my first
name throughout the entire flight it was
kind it was friendly and it gave me the
sense that he actually cared about me so
what I want you to do is think about all
the little
tails in your business where and how can
you go the extra mile for your people
what can you do to make people just feel
that things are more personable and
thoughtful rule number seven embrace
femininity culturally speaking we've
mostly been taught that the feminine is
weak right that's why so many women man
up to run a business for me for years
and years and years it produced
incredible results but you know what at
a tremendous cost where I felt myself
and my creativity starting to just drain
down or I felt myself getting more and
more stressed less and less joyful where
I found myself feeling more and more
tired and asking the questions why
because I know my core essence so that
is one of probably the biggest mistaken
notions that we have culturally is that
the feminine is weak and it is not it is
one of the most beautiful powerful
forces within all of us and I think and
I'll speak particularly to the women who
are watching right now one of the most
profound things that you can do over the
course of your life especially if you
struggle with being in your feminine is
to understand that it will unlock your
most powerful beautiful creative life
that you can imagine which includes your
ability to kick major ass in business
and it includes your ability to heal
others rule number eight get a go-to
mantra get a go-to mantra so this
strategy involves making up just this
little phrase that you can say to
yourself in those clutch moments either
when you're about to go into a big
meeting or when you just need to sit
down and do your work Mindy Kaling whom
I love suggested this as a motto why the
[ __ ] not me
and she's got the book to back it up now
I have to say I've got my own version
that I pull out when I need it every
once in a while - you're Marie Forleo
you
okay say it back your Murray King or Leo
you've got this yeah you do chest bump
now a little science note here when it
comes to motivational self-talk research
shows that talking to yourself in the
third person can help you actually feel
less anxiety and perform better so get
yourself a go-to mantra and some bonus
points if you use your first name rule
number nine serve if you've got all your
attention on yourself thinking well
what's gonna generate a whole bunch of
likes or what's gonna get people talking
about me or what's gonna make me more
famous or me more relevant or me more
popular you are thinking about
concentration in the wrong damn way
because whether you realize it or not
you're prioritizing self importance over
being of service you're thinking about
what you can get versus what you can
give which is always a losing
proposition this is especially true on
social when you're locked into what I
call the mimimi mind that's a guaranteed
way to make sure that you feel desperate
anxious and unworthy and I don't know
anybody who can come up with great
content ideas when they're feeling
desperate anxious or unworthy do you of
course not
and rule number ten the last 24 a very
special bonus clip is try many things I
was always into a lot of different
things I had a ton of energy I remember
I would make up dances with my friends
and like choreograph stuff in the living
room and then I would go and I remember
actually having Encyclopedia Brittanica
and like copying it down and like
rewriting the content making new
pictures and creating things so as a
little girl I was always wanting to
learn new things do new things and
create stuff you know I was cheerleader
so I was and by the way I wasn't a
cheerleader for a while I got rejected
so many times I tried out I can't even
tell you I would practice in my living
room I'd put the video camera up to try
and like figure out why my arm wasn't
straight enough
but I always just wanted to express
myself in all these different ways and
when you know my parents kept these
great books of when I was little where
you kind of record what your kids want
and what they're into and all those
things and I remember in the section
where it says well what do you want to
be when you grow up
it was always five to seven things it
was never just one thing and they were
all completely different it was like
from dancer to teacher to model to
actress to writer like all these
different kind of professions that
sounded fascinating to me so that was me
when I was little I was all over the
place
now I have a special bonus clip from
Murray on how to take risks that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that is
time for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching
the video to taking an action here we go
question number one what is your go-to
mantra number two where do you need to
be more consistent and number three
what's the standard that you need to
raise in your business or your life and
if you like this video and will take
action after watching it give me a hash
tag believe down the comments as well
after I look left Wall Street I went on
a bit of an odyssey to figure out what I
was supposed to do and I just went back
to myself okay I'm really passionate
about business and I'm also very
creative so how can I figure out how to
do both of these things as a livelihood
and I thought that magazine publishing
would be that perfect mix I loved
magazines I loved the fact that there
was commerce and there was a doctoral
side and you know at first I worked at
Gourmet magazine in the ad sales
department and that was cool but again I
started kind of looking ahead at the
road ahead and I looked at the publisher
seat and I said I don't want to be my
boss and if I don't want to climb this
ladder what am I doing here I'm wasting
their time in my time and I thought well
maybe I'm just still too much in the
business side you know I'm in the ad
side of the magazines maybe I need to be
on the editorial side and so I got a job
at Mademoiselle and that was on the
fashion end of things and that was cool
and I was again super grateful to have a
job I was learning a lot but I looked
ahead at the editor-in-chief spot and I
was like gosh I don't know if this is me
and I started kind of just tooling
around online and at the time life
coaching was a totally new profession it
was like very you know no one had heard
of it before but when I looked at this
article and I was like 23 something in
me lit up about this new profession and
even though it sounded crazy I'm like
who the heck is gonna hire a 23 year old
life coach I was rolling my eyes at
myself I couldn't deny that it felt
right it felt more right than anything I
had ever done and so I started studying
coaching at night I signed up for a
three-year training program and every
night when I'd go home from work at the
magazine I would do my classes online
and do everything I could fast-forward
six months and I got a call from HR and
I had a job offer at Vogue and this was
like my huge fork in the road because
Vogue is clearly an incredible
publication it's like you know do I go
on this path best fashion magazine in
the world or do I quit my job and start
this weird life coaching business where
I don't even believe myself kind of but
I can't deny it sounds awesome and so I
really thought about I said I got to do
this and I quit my job and I decided to
start my own business 23
if you want more Murray check that the
first top-10 I made on her the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there when I was bartending I
was fully bartending like I wasn't
talking to myself about oh my god I
should be dancing right now or I should
be working on my coaching practice while
I was growing my personal coaching
practice